su hermano pequeño de 9 años viven en un
orfanato desde hace más de dos años su
padre los dejó allí porque no podía
hacerse cargo de ellos sheina se ha
adaptado a su nueva vida lejos de su
hogar
estamos bien aquí nos cuidan nos dan de
comer
después de las clases puedo jugar con
mis compañeras de la orfanato que son
ahora mi familia
he hecho mucho de menos a mi padre pero
aquí puedo ir a la escuela y voy a poder
seguir estudiando
quiero ser doctora cuando sea mayor
así no le gusta ir al colegio estudiar y
aprender en las aulas hay otros niños y
niñas en su misma situación Por lo que
no se siente sola a pesar de las
dificultades que la rodean syna es de
las primeras de la clase bueno las ramas
se alimentan de la savia y las raíces se
alimentan de la tierra muy bien muy bien
Qué niña más lista cada día de la
escuela cuando terminan las actividades
es un momento triste para la niña padres
de autobuses escolares esperan el patio
a otros alumnos que regresaran a sus
casas mientras que seine y sus
compañeros de orfanato se organizan en
filas para el recuento y vuelven a su
rutina en este hogar infantil
en el Líbano hay un sistema de acogida
por lo que son las instituciones
religiosas las que se encargan de cuidar
a menores desamparados hay 300 centros
como este repartidos por el país que
albergan a 40.000 menores vulnerables
pero que la profunda crisis económica
que atraviesa el país ha crecido número
de niños acogidos en El orfanato del
sagrará mientras que las donaciones han
disminuido
recibimos mil solicitudes en el verano
de 2022 una demanda inusual no estamos
recibiendo ayudas del gobierno y con las
donaciones no vamos a poder aguantar
mucho más me inquieta si la situación no
mejora el próximo año voy a tener que
prescindir de la mitad del personal del
orfanato
desde 1977 esta institución religiosa ha
servido de Amparo para miles de niños en
condiciones vulnerables pero debido a
las dificultades financieras se cierne
la preocupación ante la posibilidad de
no poder continuar con esta misión
social
tiene 11 años como sheina pero hace
tiempo que no ha pisado una escuela su
padre está enfermo y él sale a trabajar
para ayudar económicamente a su familia
Tengo ocho hijos y cinco de ellos están
vendiendo en las calles para poder pagar
los gastos y el alquiler si nos echan no
tendremos donde vivir somos muy pobres y
no tenemos ninguna ayuda tengo problemas
de corazón e hígado y me fatigo mucho
los niños trabajando para ayudar a
mantener los hogares lebaneses son una
constante las cifras se han disparado
desde 2020 Según micef uno de cada dos
menores estás puesto al trabajo infantil
u otro tipo de abusos contra la infancia
en el mercado lotes de calcetines que
venderá después aviandantes y
conductores en las atestadas calles del
centro
se lanza ante los vehículos detenidos en
el tráfico en busca compradores muchas
veces ofrece los calcetines al doble de
lo que los ha comprado para sacarse un
beneficio pero en pocas ocasiones logra
venderlos trabaja hasta media noche
porque no puede volver a casa con las
manos vacías
no puedo hacer otra cosa tengo que
ayudar a mi familia mi padre está
enfermo
a veces llego a casa muy cansado pero si
no consigo dinero mi padre se enfada
conmigo
Me gustaría ir al colegio pero tengo que
trabajar
detrás de estos muros pintados por niños
de la calle se encuentra el centro rival
que coordina del Karim una pequeña gota
en el océano para combatir el trabajo
infantil en el Líbano gracias a su
equipo educadores menores que están
creciendo en un ambiente inadecuado
realizan actividades de aprendizaje y
juegos en vez de trabajar en las calles
es un problema enorme cada vez hay más
niños que no van a la escuela y se ponen
a trabajar o a mendigar en las calles
nosotros intentamos atraerlos a nuestros
centros pero no podemos interceder
porque nos enfrentamos a las mafias o a
los padres que le pegan a sus hijos
porque no quieren que dejen de trabajar
porque son los niños los que traen el
dinero a la casa
la crisis del Líbano está destrozando el
futuro de miles de niños cada vez son
más las familias que viven en la pobreza
lo que genera mayor desigualdad social
entre los menores con menos
oportunidades escolares y con una
alarmante subida de los casos de trabajo
infantil la crisis cierra las puertas de
un futuro a una generación de niños
libaneses como cena en Holanda